today I'm starting with explosive and
stunning Revelations from the Dominion
lawsuit against Fox News we have learned
in the last few hours that Rupert
Murdoch of news corporation admitted
under oath that yes Fox News hosts were
promoting election lies now we all knew
this but it is a massive story of huge
consequence yeah Rupert Murdoch can
afford to pay most likely whatever comes
of this lawsuit but this genuinely could
could harm Fox News in a serious way
let's get right to what we've learned
mediaite has a report Rupert Murdoch
admitted under oath Fox News hosts
promoted election lies on air despite a
raft of evidence revealing that many
hosts privately knew that the claims
made by then president Donald Trump and
his surrogates were false stunning new
details emerged in more court documents
released yesterday afternoon
in the Dominion voting system defamation
lawsuit against Fox News as chairman of
Fox News parent company of fox
Corporation Murdoch is a central figure
in the 1.6 billion dollar damages claim
according to the copy of the filing
obtained by mediaite Murdoch admitted in
a deposition last month that fall
selection claims were promoted by top
hosts at the Cable News Network quote
they endorsed I would have liked us to
be stronger in denouncing it in
hindsight said Murdoch Murdoch was asked
to host Janine Pirro endorsed the claims
Murdoch said I think so he said Lou
Dobbs endorsed the claims quote a lot
and Sean Hannity did so a bit
when asked if he could have told Fox to
stop inviting Trump lawyers Sydney
Powell and Rudy Giuliani on the air
Murdoch replied I could have but I
didn't arguably as big a revelation
Murdoch helped the Trump campaign by
providing Biden television ads to Jared
Kushner before they ran on Fox News
these are massive Revelations keep in
mind that Fox News hosted a presidential
debate in 2020 as if they were some kind
of neutral Observer or Arbiter but
behind the scenes look at what was going
on
um Yahoo news via Bloomberg also with an
interesting article worth looking at
Murdoch testified Fox commentators
endorsed Trump's 2020 election lie Fox
News Fox Corporation chairman Rupert
Murdoch testified that Fox's popular
commentators endorsed that's the word he
used endorse Trump's false claim that
the 2020 election was rigged even though
Murdoch said he doubted it right away he
doubted it right away
um there's an interesting transcript
here where it says Murdoch testified
that he doubted Trump's conspiracy
theory right away is it is it it is fair
to say you seriously doubted any claim
of massive election fraud Murdoch was
asked by a lawyer oh yeah Murdoch said
and you seriously doubted it from the
beginning he was asked yeah Murdoch
replied I mean we thought everything was
on the up and up I think that was shown
when we announced Arizona of course
referring to when Fox declared Biden the
winner of Arizona
this is an incredible media story and
you know whatever you think of of uh uh
the the sort of Gossip World there was
that very big Hulk Hogan
um case involving because I didn't
follow it I don't even know which
tabloid it was and he essentially put
them out of business and there was sort
of like do you care about Hulk Hogan but
then there was what does this mean more
generally about the caution that media
Outlets have to have and this could be a
significantly more a consequential story
now there's a couple different things
that I think are important to mention it
would be really great
if this seriously damaged Fox News as
far as the broadcast side now that's not
because I want to suppress speech it's
not because I want to violate anyone's
First Amendment rights it's because
actions
should have consequences and one of the
things that I've said before is that the
bigger your platform the more seriously
you should take your responsibility for
what you put out on air and the more you
should want to be accurate in what you
say
and even as it applies to my program now
that the show is as big as it is which
is still way smaller than these other
platforms we're talking about I am extra
careful when it comes to making sure
that I'm getting as close to the truth
always on the program when it comes to
the facts that I'm presenting then I
give my opinion sure it's not that I
didn't care about it when the show was
smaller but I sense the responsibility
and I know that the repercussions for
getting even Minor Details wrong are
greater the larger you are Fox News as
one of the three biggest cable news
networks and I know people say David
it's not really news I know but we're
colloquially we're talking about the
three biggest cable news networks MSNBC
CNN Fox News they not accidentally but
knowingly spent months promoting claims
about the election that they knew to be
lies the result of which was I don't
want to say irreversibly corrosive to
our democracy but it has still damaged
our democracy to this day as we continue
to see these claims being made now as
far as the impact the lawsuit is likely
to have on Fox News even if they deserve
for it to be very damaging they will
continue to lie they will continue to
monetize by playing to the lowest common
denominator of the American right wing
even if on a personal level Hannity and
Ingram and Tucker and Rupert Murdoch all
know that they're saying things that
aren't true and that they're inviting
guests on to say things that aren't true
as Tucker Carlson knew about Sydney
Powell
the money part of it
you know Rupert Murdoch can probably
afford whatever comes of this is the
reality his goal now is to minimize the
damage to the platform
and it remains to be seen where this
goes but an extraordinary Revelation and
my guess is we are going to learn even
more in the days to come the Republican
Civil War is not letting up anytime soon
in fact it's growing Republican you know
I don't I don't want to say Insider but
establishment Republican Paul Ryan a
major figure in the last you know 10 15
years of Republican politics is now
openly saying
we will lose if Trump is the nominee
I am anti-trump and I will not go to the
Republican National Convention in 2024
if Donald Trump is indeed the nominee
let's take a look at a couple of very
interesting Clips here is Paul Ryan
speaking at the Tommy Thompson Center on
public leadership and he says I'm not
for Trump because I want to win I'm a
never again Trumper because I want to
win we're going to lose with him look
the evidence is pretty clear we lost the
house in 18 because of trump we lost the
presidency obviously in 201 we lost the
senate in 20 because of trump then there
are I by my account five Senate seats
this cycle in 22 we lost because of
trump and by most sort of smart people
in our party by most of their
measurements we lost about 12 to 15
seats in the house because of trump so
Kevin McCarthy would have had a nice
20-some vote cushion had an opera for
Trump so the point I'm making is we know
we lose with him and so we know we will
lose with him again if we nominate this
guy especially and January 6 happened
after the 20 election
so you think it became more popular with
swing voters in the wild counties you
know since January 6. my point is we're
going to lose with the guy so let's now
is Paul Ryan correct about this I
actually don't know I mean listen if you
look at the latest polling
it doesn't look terrible for Trump
assuming he can win the Republican
nomination you look at a recent Emerson
College poll released um released I
think today uh taken February 24th and
25th there's an A minus rated pollster
on Biden versus Trump they have Trump uh
plus three
um in the popular vote
it's February almost March of 2023 so we
you could say this isn't really worth
much but it is not obvious that Trump
can't win if he does become the nominee
in 2024. uh morning consult which is a
b-rated pollster has Biden plus two
against Trump
um in an Echelon insights poll has Biden
plus three over Trump the point is it's
not a foregone conclusion that Donald
Trump can't defeat Joe Biden if that's
the rematch uh of 2020 in 2024 but Paul
Ryan's opinion is that Trump can't win
and he wants to win now we have a couple
of other Clips here as Paul Ryan being
interviewed by Fox 6 uh and he is
continuing to pile on I'm backing the
person not named Donald Trump so I I
don't really have a dog in the fight
other than that if we nominate Trump
again we're going to lose again it's
just that clear we lost with him in 18
20 and 22 we know this he will cost us
another election so I'm just excited
about somebody not named yeah and then
just one more clip here of Paul Ryan
saying he will not attend the Republican
National Convention if Trump is the
nominee for the Republican National
Convention in Milwaukee where will you
be it uh it depends on who the nominee
is
I'll be here if it's somebody not named
Trump
you won't show up if it's not yeah I'm
not interested in participating in that
no even in Wisconsin
even Wisconsin so listen there's a
really let's there's two parts to this
there's the Republican Civil War aspect
to it and there's the Ken Trump win
aspect which we don't have a definitive
answer to right now the Civil War part
continues to be uh very interesting
where you see people in the vein of Paul
Ryan Mitt Romney Adam kinzinger and
others who have the I hate to call it
audacity they just have the sort of uh
honesty I guess to say what we know more
Republicans than just them are thinking
they don't care if they are on the outs
when it comes to being friendly with
those who are in positions of power if
Trump wins and Trump's in power we all
know Paul Ryan will have no influence
Mitt Romney will have no influence and
they're okay with that for one reason or
another fine okay let that that's no no
problem whatsoever the question of
listen
in 18 Republicans did poorly because of
trump
in 20 they lost the Senate and they lost
the presidency and then in 22 the red
wave that was supposed to be actually
saw them lose a seat in the Senate and
take the slimmest of minorities in the
house Trump's been a disaster completely
true the reason I wouldn't count out
Trump in 24 if he is indeed the nominee
is when you are out of power and you are
making the argument things are terrible
and you've got to put me back in to fix
it as transparent as that is as you and
I of course know just like Trump made
all these promises he didn't keep in
2016 and just like he wouldn't have kept
the promises he made in 2020 he's not
going to do any of the things he's going
to do he's not going to fix any of the
problems that he claims he's going to
fix if he wins in 24 but being on the
outside and being able to say everybody
in power is ruining it bring me in and I
will fix it that can actually motivate
people who otherwise wouldn't vote at
all to vote and that may actually be
what the 24 election hinges on so I
would not assume that Trump can't win
and I think that it would be a very big
mistake to do what many did in 2016
which is to laugh off the idea of trump
at least now we know he did once win
and that should remind us he could win
again but the Civil War aspect of this
is going to become very interesting
particularly as more candidates
announced that they are going to be
running against Trump in that Republican
primary race so we're going to continue
following all of it I do want to invite
you to subscribe to the YouTube channel
at youtube.com the davidpackman show we
do desperately need your help in getting
to that 2 million subscriber number and
I also want to remind you we are now
dubbing uh roughly two-thirds of our
daily content into the Spanish language
elements of Spanish you can find on the
Spanish Channel at davidpackman.com
Spanish Let Your Friends neighbors
parents cousins anybody who is looking
for this type of content but in Spanish
rather than English let them know
davidpackman.com Spanish
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
one of the most common questions I get
from people who meet me and learn what I
do is how exactly is this program funded
because a lot of people understandably
don't know like how does an independent
media show exist and as many of you know
we make a little bit of money from like
the YouTube Partner program and a little
bit from advertising but we really
depend on individual members people like
you who just say hey I like what you're
doing I'm going to get a membership and
you can do that at joinpakman.com it
would be worth it even if you got
nothing just to support what we're doing
I think but we actually do include a lot
of great perks with a membership we do
an extra show every single day for our
members called the bonus show we provide
a daily commercial free audio or video
feed of the show whether you you prefer
to watch or listen we provide both
commercial free we host members only
Town Hall events where only our members
are invited to chat with me and we all
also have a sound board mimicking the
sound board I have here in front of me
truth essential uh that's another great
member benefit sign up at joinpakman.com
very much appreciate everybody who has
joined the ranks of membership in the
last few days I have absolutely brutal
video for you Tennessee Republican
Governor Bill Lee is going hard
anti-drag and anti-trans and was
confronted with pictures of himself
dressed in drag years ago this is just
unbelievable let's go right to the video
first and then I will tell you all of
the details but this is oof this this is
something take a look at this
children's transgender therapy that's on
your desk drag Bill heads back to the
Center for a quick Amendment before it's
your desk comfortable signing those
types of legislation yeah I expected
Josh
what a ridiculous ridiculous question
that is conflating something like that
to sexualized
sex realized in front of children which
is a very serious subject Andy what you
got
[Music]
you Andy
I was just wondering if you're aware of
any
cases or instances
are you aware of specifics
I think that the concern is uh what's
right there in that class in that
building children that are potentially
exposed to sexualized entertainment to
obscenity and we need obscenity come on
dude you need to make sure that they're
not I think that's something that should
happen in Tennessee that will because of
this bill would you be okay
appreciate it
because this is you this is you at a
high school Governor this right here is
you at a high school yeah is it only
illegal when gay people do it
have you talked to your sister about the
bill guy
all right so the everything about this
is just wacky first and foremost you
know the the idea that there is
um some
oh predatory nature to the drag queen
story hours or we've already talked
about it we've we've looked at it
extensively there's a sort of mishmash
happening which really shouldn't between
the drag queen stuff and the trans
bathroom stuff and these really are two
separate issues we interviewed uh a drag
performer a couple of weeks ago who
explained like you might be trans and
also be a drag performer but there
really are two separate things let's
look at a couple articles excuse me a
couple articles here The Daily Beast uh
drag Banning Tennessee governor shrugs
off old drag pick as a lighthearted
tradition
with Billy poised to sign a bill
outlawing drag performances imagine that
an apparent photo from his high school
yearbook has surfaced uh the other thing
that was mentioned in all of this by the
way is obscenity that they're concerned
with Tennessee already has obscenity
laws so if the concern is obscenity or
sexualization that already is handled by
Tennessee law and so claiming you need
this new law doesn't actually make any
sense a photo emerged writes The Daily
Beast on Reddit over the weekend from
the Franklin High yearbook in 77 where
Lee attended purportedly showing Lee
dressed as a woman along with the
caption hard Hard Luck Woman but that's
different Lee's office told The Daily
Beast saying lighthearted School
Traditions shouldn't be conflated with
what the state is Banning the bill
specifically protects children from
obscene sexualized entertainment and any
attempt to conflate this serious issue
with light-hearted school Traditions is
dishonest honest and disrespectful to
Tennessee families when asked during the
press conference if you remembered it he
didn't deny the photo was of him but
said it's it's a ridiculous question NBC
news reporting Tennessee governor
appears to have dressed in drag an art
form he wants to restrict
there are sort of like three different
things here
as is so often the case with these
right-wing clowns there's the personal
hypocrisy now on the issue of drag you
wouldn't think like how does this keep
happening Kerry Lake I give very
dangerous drag queens Carey Lake uh
organized if I recall correctly a drag
performance and at minimum attended it
uh Bill Lee we're Banning drag because
it's sexualized and obscene and this and
that oh he'd rest in Drag and actually
the law already bans obscenity okay so
the one part is the hypocrisy the second
part is as I started to mention the
actual thing they say is the problem
with drag isn't really the problem but
if it were meaning the obscenity or
whatever A lot of these states already
have so-called anti-obscenity laws on
the book so you wouldn't actually need
these bills and then number three is
what the reporter asked which is is
there a single specific example you can
site of what it is that this bill would
stop and you know we went through this
with the Trans bathroom stuff which is
okay so it's going to stop uh men who
say I'm a woman in order to go into the
women's room and spy on young girls and
take pictures and we already have laws
against that and there are no examples
of that happening from states that are
more Progressive when it comes to the
trans bathroom stuff so it's again a
solution in search of a problem to
Virtue signal if you want to learn more
about virtue signaling we have a clip on
the YouTube channel that I did last week
so nonsense all around
great to see Bill Lee confronted these
people are clowns these people are
virtue signaling they're playing into
these culture wars and they're doing it
in a horrifyingly authoritarian way
all right listen I know people in my
audience some people in my audience are
going to get mad at me because there are
people in my audience who love Marianne
Williamson
and they say Marianne is willing to make
criticisms of the status quo that many
can that it won't make but I'm sorry
guys I can't take the new age self-help
gurus seriously
and I am going to tell you what I think
and I know some of you will be mad and
you're going to email me and that's okay
it's great that Marianne Williamson is
willing to say things like both parties
are widely controlled by corporations
that's great she says it it's not the
type of thing you hear Joe Biden say but
that notwithstanding I am not super
excited about Marianne Williamson
announcing that she will be challenging
President Joe Biden for the 2024
Democratic nomination
I'm just not excited I don't believe
that she is someone who could seriously
do the job and it is very difficult for
me to take her seriously based on her
verse basically being a version of
Deepak Chopra that's that's the way I
now perfectly nice individual I've had
her on the program
I I love her whole thing about we need
more love and all that I love all of it
but this is not something that I'm going
to get excited about and uh uh I'll I'll
talk a little bit about it and I know
there are people in my audience who like
this the fact that Marianne Williamson
makes criticisms that many Democrats
aren't willing to make doesn't to me
mean that she should be president
there's lots of people that make
criticisms that I find to be real good
criticisms that I wouldn't go and say
well make them president she was able to
gain a big Reddit and Twitter following
she capitalized on some meme culture
she's interesting like I get it she
holds some reasonable left-wing views
that I perfectly well agree with she's
for Medicare for all I think she's for
DACA granting some kind of permanent
status for those who were brought to the
U.S undocumented before they were adults
I think she's for the green New Deal she
seems very serious about climate change
that's all great
is there any evidence that she can or
would actually be able to do anything
about it but more importantly I just
can't take people seriously when they
have a history of touting all sorts of
woo-woo pseudoscience including sort of
flirting with anti-vax stuff although
she's kind of backed off of it a little
when some of the repercussions weren't
so good she's promoted this Prosperity
Gospel stuff that you often hear from
the Christian preachers you can look at
her 2012 book for examples of that she
sounds like Deepak Chopra half the time
with these unintelligible quotes that
are sort of like meant to sound profound
but they don't really mean anything just
one example is when she said everyone
feels on some level like an alien in
this world because we are we come from
another Realm Of Consciousness and long
for home
that just as easily could be a Deepak
Chopra quote another example Yin is
feminine Earth Yang is masculine Sky
when God is seen as he the soul is seen
as she just archetypes Spirit
impregnates soul
it's just not for me it's not for me one
other one God is Big swine flu is small
see every cell of your body filled with
Divine Light pour God's love on our
immune systems truth protects
it's just not for me guys Okay so
totally fine that she's running good for
her I have no problem with her running
she should run if she wants to it's just
not for me and hopefully people in my
audience understand that now one
argument that I saw three people emailed
me about this and all three said the
same thing Marianne Williamson is going
to push Biden to the left
I don't see how and what I mean by that
is if Biden runs for re-election there's
not going to be like a real primary and
Marianne Williamson isn't going to get
on the debate stage with Joe Biden now
you could say well she should she should
be fine
she's not going to push Biden left
because if Biden runs she's not going to
get on the debate stage no one will pay
attention
and I do think it's also important to
mention that if she somehow managed to
become the nominee and somehow manage to
become president
she would get nothing done she would
literally get nothing done she doesn't
know how to get bills passed she has no
idea about any of that stuff and I have
no confidence if the completely
impossible were to happen if someone
paid attention and she won the
nomination and she became president I
don't think she would be able to get
anything done I don't believe that it is
serious I think it's perfectly fine and
interesting I completely support her
right to run but it is not for me email
me insults I'm ready folks we'll have
all of today's Clips on our Instagram
which you can find by searching
Instagram for David Pacman show
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show today
we're going to be speaking with Dr
Robert waldinger who's the director of
the Harvard study of adult development
and also co-author of the new book The
Good Life Lessons From the world's
longest scientific study of Happiness a
really great to have you on I appreciate
your time well it's great to be here
thanks for having me so one of the
really interesting things about this
study which started in 1938 is many
studies on happiness are of different
groups of people sometimes times from
different countries across different
time periods and it can become very
difficult to really compare apples to
apples for for lack of a better term and
one of the interesting things about this
study that now has gone on uh more than
eight decades is it followed the same
individuals and families it's very
extensive asked a ton of questions
hundreds of measurements includes blood
work brain scans I mean you're really
approaching this from a sort of cover
every aspect perspective can you tell us
just a little bit about how this study
started the number of people that were
originally part of it and the number
that that are still with us today
sure let's start it as two studies that
didn't know about each other started on
different parts of the Harvard
University campus one was a study begun
at Harvard Health Service the Student
Health Service with sophomores from
Harvard College
and the other was a study of delinquency
a study of delinquent and non-delinquent
boys from Boston's poorest neighborhoods
from the most troubled families
268 Harvard College undergraduates 456
inner city boys and all of them were
studied as a way to understand thriving
how kids moved from childhood into
adulthood on good developmental paths
including the kids who were born with so
many strikes against them you know into
such disadvantaged circumstances
so it was Radical for its time to be
doing these studies of human thriving
and then eventually my predecessor put
the two studies together and started
looking at them as contrasting groups
when we look at the popular literature
on happiness there are all these often
repeated ideas or rules of thumb or
whatever the case may be one of them is
once you make seventy five thousand
dollars a year it's equivalent when you
get beyond that you're not really
anymore sometimes the term is satisfied
with your life sometimes the term happy
is used another one that you often hear
is later in life
having spent more time in the office
rarely correlates to more happiness
whereas having spent more time with
family and having more close
relationships does and you know then
five years go by and there's another
study that comes out and it has a
slightly different different result on
some of those sort of like lowest
hanging fruit things that are often
discussed what has this study determined
well we just determined that the inner
city
group was no less happy than the
privileged Harvard group and that's more
consistent with other studies that say
basically once you get your basic
economic needs met then making more and
more money doesn't do it doesn't
increase your happiness and that seems
to be a pretty robust findings across a
lot of groups of people is there
something to that 75 000 number that you
found no not 75 000 per se and of course
it varies depending on whether you live
in you know the middle of New York City
or you live in rural Iowa right it's
really the question of when when you
have your basic needs met once you've
gotten to that point in terms of income
then more money doesn't do it for you
then you can make millions more and on
average people aren't happier there's
this phrase nobody uh is on their
deathbed wishing they spent more time at
the office right you you you hear that
very often yeah what does the study have
to say about that Dynamic well we ask
people when our first generation folks
were in their 80s we asked them to look
back on their lives and we asked what
are you proudest of and what do you
regret the most and what they regretted
the most particularly the men because
this was the World War II generation
they regretted the most spending too
much time at work and not spending
enough time with the people they cared
about
what they were proudest of was
um was to a person something to do with
their relationships so you know they
didn't say I made a ton of money or I
won all these Awards you know or I was
famous and we had people who were all of
those things
they said I was a good boss I was a good
spouse I was a good friend a good parent
right so when they were looking back on
what was most meaningful it wasn't about
achievement it was about Connections uh
is it true that John F Kennedy was one
of the original participants
it is true and the only reason I can
tell you that is because he was outed by
another journalist about 15 years ago
otherwise we are bound to keep in
confidence the identities of all of the
people in our study so you know in fact
the book has stories of real people
woven all through the book but the the
names and The Superficial details are
disguised to make sure that we protect
their privacy
so it sounds like
um money Beyond a certain level not a
big contributor to happiness Fame not a
big contributor to happiness having
spent a lot of time at the office not
not necessarily A contributor
relationships of of different kinds yes
family friendships Etc what else are the
kind of positively correlated
um stories that that you find
taking care of your health matters a lot
you know it's it's like our grandmothers
could have told us that but what we find
and lots of studies find is that you
know getting regular Health Care not
smoking not abusing alcohol and drugs
regular exercise not becoming obese all
of those things make huge differences in
years of life lived and also in years of
healthy life so it really matters a lot
to take care of your health
um the surprising thing for us was the
finding about relationships being so
important because at first we thought
well how could relationships actually
get into your body and and change your
physiology and now for the last 10 years
we've been studying that many other
groups have too and we're understanding
that this is a very powerful robust
connection between
relationships and physical health
what about uh religion because there's
religion can be a tough one where it can
be hard to separate the effect of being
part of a community and the social
aspects versus the religiosity itself
and there's many many studies on this
did you find anything that would be sort
of clear in in the data about religious
participation
well we ask people do you have a
religious practice do you have a
spiritual practice
and there were people who did and there
were people who did not and when we
compared those two groups
neither group was on average happier so
didn't make a difference in your
happiness whether you were spiritual or
religious or not but many of the
religious and spiritual people said that
during times of difficulty their
spiritual practices were helpful to them
so that's more I guess qualitative than
quantitative yeah
when you compare the two groups no one
group isn't happier what about uh travel
because one of the things that's often
written about travel is because when you
travel you're not in your routine
um time seems to go by slower which
often one of the things we read is that
over time you know years go by very very
quickly and part of this seems to be
that there's no cognitive a difference
day to day when you're kind of in your
in your normal day-to-day thing so that
travel is an interesting way and and one
might think there might be some
correlation to happiness as well there
is there anything
we did not study that specifically but
what you're saying makes a lot of sense
and and what we do find is that more
cognitive stimulation Keeps Us sharper
over time and that includes being
connected with other people so one of
the the effects we think of
relationships on keeping our brains
healthy yeah is that it stimulates us
people are always unpredictable they're
moving targets what what you're gonna
say to me next is something I don't know
right and that keeps my brain clicking
on all cylinders that's a good thing for
the brain and I think what you're
pointing out is that travel can do the
same thing that's why time seems to go
more slowly during travel because we're
like on alert like what am I going to
see now how do I find my way here it's
it's all of those challenges that we
think Keeps Us healthy cognitively as we
get older one of the things that is it's
not unique to the United States but it's
certainly been written about a lot in
the United States is the trend that
people move relatively frequently in
modern American society much more
commonly than in other parts of the
world don't live near their families nor
where they grew up I was recently
reading Jared Diamond's book about
traditional societies and he said a big
difference there aside from all sorts of
other differences is that in more
traditional societies people tend to
live near where they grew up and near
their family most of their lives in the
United States it's increasingly uncommon
was there something garnered from the
study related to that about those who
kind of stay what we might call close to
home versus those that don't
what we found was a difference in the
inner city group from the Harvard group
and that made a whole lot of sense
because the Harvard group was gathered
from all over the country Harvard
College brings in undergrads from
everywhere in the U.S and sometimes
abroad
unlike the inner city group where they
were
chosen because they lived in Boston
their families lived in Boston and what
we found then in the next generation was
that of course more of the inner city
group lived in this area stayed near
their families now what we have not done
is an analysis that compares are those
second generation people in the Inner
City Group happier than the more widely
dispersed Harvard people I expect that
research exists we just haven't done it
interesting in terms of the
relationships lots of studies on
friendship that look at number of
friends but also quality of relationship
and what you see frequently repeated in
popular Publications is it's not about
having many friends as one ages it's
about having a few uh very strong or
rewarding relationships that really
seems to correlate not only with
happiness but sometimes even like a
health claim will be made
um what what about that distinction
well what we find is that you know as
with so many things when you follow
thousands of lives one size never fits
all so we're all on a spectrum
temperamentally from introversion
shyness to extroversion and most of us
are somewhere in the middle but there
are extremes and what we find is that
shy people
find lots of people around them to be
stressful so actually having a lot of
connections in your life could be more
stressful if you're temperamentally
introverted on the other hand
extroverted people get their energy from
people so they may need a lot of people
so what we find is that it's a highly
individual matter and that each of us
can really discern for ourselves what's
the amount of connection that works for
me in my life and how can I work to have
the amount that feels right to me that's
interesting I mean holding all else
equal do you know whether introverts or
extroverts seem to be happier
I don't know that I do know that for
example Susan Kane some of her work that
there are people who work on this and I
don't believe people have found that
introverts or extroverts are happier
than the opposite extreme at all
um I think one of the complicating
factors is that our culture
um
glorifies extraversion yeah you know
being a party animal right you know
that's like an iconic character in films
and literature on social media right and
so that bias toward extroversion can
make introverted people feel like there
may be something wrong with them what we
know is there isn't anything wrong with
them at all it's perfectly normal
adaptive some of the most wonderful most
brilliant most talented people are shy
not a problem
uh the book is called the good life
lessons from the world's longest
scientific study of Happiness we've been
speaking with the books co-author Dr
Robert waldinger really appreciate your
time and insights today thank you for
having me
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
a very confused and swollen looking
failed former president Donald Trump is
promising a global trade war that would
be disastrous for the American economy
in his latest teleprompter tirade
remember Barack Obama was bad for using
a teleprompter Obama but Trump is I
guess good for using a teleprompter I
don't know this is Trump's new series of
quote policy statements where he's
laying out supposed policy that he will
enact if he becomes president of the
United States I can see why Republicans
are running away from talking about
policy because every idea is a complete
and total disaster will
um let's just jump into this thing in
the middle here is Trump announcing
truly just a whacked global trade war
that would not be good for the American
economy take a look at this we will
phase in a system Universal Baseline
tariffs on most foreign products on top
of this higher tariffs will increase
incrementally depending on how much
individual foreign countries devalue
their currency they devalue their
currency to take advantage of the United
States as tariffs are did you notice
that jump cut there Farm producers go up
taxes on American Producers will go down
and go down very substantially and that
means a lot of jobs coming in not only
will this system end our gaping trade
deficits and they are massive right now
gaping and bring back millions of
American jobs it will also bring
trillions and trillions of dollars
pouring into the United States Treasury
from foreign countries that allow us to
invest that money in American workers I
will Implement a bold series of reforms
to completely eliminate dependence on
China in all critical areas we will
revoke China's most favored nation trade
status and adopt a four-year plan to
phase out all China these Imports of
essential Goods everything from
Electronics to Steel to Pharmaceuticals
we will also adopt new rules to stop U.S
companies from pouring investments into
China and to stop China from buying up
America allowing all of those
Investments That clearly Serve American
interests we're not going to allow bad
things to happen to our country anymore
it's bad all right so listen this guy is
clueless about trade now on there's
there's so much here genuinely the first
thing about this is the entire framing
of this trade and tariff story is that
there's no cost to doing this stuff of
course bring the supply chains home hire
American buy American build American
these are completely reasonable economic
nationalist ideas that I could get
behind and it they're not bad ideas in
some theoretical sense but people like
Trump and many and all Republicans and
many Democrats as well they pretend that
there's no other side to this thing and
also they pretend like this will
obviously create American jobs now first
and foremost the tariffs that Trump did
with Chinese products while he was
President a recent study found
that the totality of that trade policy
cost the U.S about 250 million jobs okay
you can find that study you can read
about it it's it's sort of a technical
paper maybe there's a summary of it but
it didn't actually create jobs it cost
the United States jobs that's number one
it's not the silver bullet on jobs that
Trump believes it to be but what Trump
and others never tell you is by the way
if we do this things will be insanely
more expensive on the one hand they
complain about inflation and how much
eggs cost and how much everything costs
that Define complaint you can if things
are too expensive it's perfectly
reasonable to complain but then out of
the other side of their mouths they say
we're going to produce everything here
but they don't mention how expensive
everything's going to be the United
States through a series of cumulative
decisions over the last 40 to 50 years
has decided and when I mean we've
decided it's not
Reagan decided or Clinton decided it's
the totality of our policy has been
based on the idea that we prefer cheap
stuff rather than paying more but making
it all here in the United States
if all of these things Trump is talking
about
were manufactured here in the United
States
at least he's saying it's a 40-year plan
because it'll take 40 years to actually
make all of that happen and completely
restructure all of these Supply chains
at least he's being honest but it will
become insanely more expensive and
people already can't afford the
inflation we've seen while still being
heavily dependent on China for cheap
stuff which we prefer and when I say we
prefer what I mean is our economy is
built on that so the global trade war
that Trump is talking about will never
happen and if it did it would be insane
what it would do to prices in this
teleprompter you know deranged
teleprompter speech uh Trump also of
course attacked Joe Biden here's the
beginning of it we'll just look at a
little more Joe Biden claims to support
American manufacturing but in reality
he's pushing the same pro-china
globalist agenda that ripped the
industrial heart out of our country he's
really not it ripped us apart Biden and
the globalist support raising remember
globalists does Trump even know what
that means no is it often just the way
to say Jews yes it's it's meaningless
guys X is on American production they
support more crippling regulations
Killing American jobs they support
skyrocketing domestic energy costs and
they support massive anti-American
multinational agreements that send our
wealth and factories overseas it's just
a word salad and remember here Trump
bemoans regulations the Trump
Administration eliminated some obama-era
regulations on rail which could be a
factor in the East Palestine train
derailment so on the one hand he bemoans
regulations on the other hand his
supposed reduction of regulations was
actually very very destructive it's very
dangerous stuff and tomorrow we're going
to get a quote from Ruth Ben geot who's
been a guest on the program where she
says that that whether it's Trump or or
DeSantis the authoritarian direction
that this stuff is going in is
extraordinarily dangerous radical and
repugnant Republican congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor green says she was
attacked at a restaurant she tweeted
quote I was attacked in a restaurant
tonight by an insane woman and screamed
at by her adult son they had no respect
for the restaurant or the staff or the
other people dining or people like me
who simply have different political
views they are self-righteous insane and
completely out of control
I was sitting at my table working with
my staff and never even noticed these
people until they turned into demons
people used to respect others even if
they had different views but not anymore
our country is gone
now there's a couple things here that I
think are important to say first of all
Marjorie Taylor green is a horrible
hypocrite here is video of her harassing
David Hogg about his activism out on the
street
first officer at Parkland had done his
job
then Nicholas Cruz wouldn't have killed
anybody in your high school or at least
protected them why are you supporting
red flag gun laws that attack our Second
Amendment right right to remember oh
someone harassed me out in public which
I've also done to people you are using
kids to get as a barrier
do you not know how to defend your
stance
look I'm an American citizen I'm a gun
owner I have a concealed carry permit I
carry a gun with for protection for
myself and you are using your lobby
and the money behind it and the kids to
try to take away my second amendment
rights
all right you get the picture so she's a
complete hypocrite nobody is allowed to
confront her but she's allowed to
confront other people and it's the same
thing as always I do think there is like
a serious
um
discussion
uh about the entire confronting people
in public thing now this has happened to
me many of you will remember about what
was it about a year and a half ago
I was confronted
um at a restaurant at an outdoor seating
Terrace I guess you would call it patio
at a restaurant where
um a young woman saw me and I could kind
of tell from across the room that that
uh she recognized me
and then as I was leaving I get onto the
sidewalk and at that point she yells
David pakman you Zionist Jew bastard
um and I ignored it
and just walked away I mean I'm aware of
it obviously because I told the story
but I didn't engage with it in any way
now had she done it while I was still
dining and having my beautiful fish and
chips which I had at that restaurant
um what would I have done I probably
still would have ignored her but I do
think that if you're at a restaurant and
you're actively harassing a patron it
would be completely reasonable for the
restaurant to say you can't behave that
way or you've got to leave right so if
in this situation where Marjorie Taylor
green was harassed she says attacked but
doesn't make any indication that there
was anything physical that happened but
she was harassed is what we could say it
would be perfectly reasonable for the
restaurant to say hey you can't yell in
here and you can't harass people so you
either you either got to shut up or
you've got to leave totally perfectly
reasonable when it comes to the the the
difficulty every time we talk about this
is when it comes to elected officials
who earn salaries paid by the taxpayers
and who choose to evade
accountability of a certain type right
you can get to a point where in your
head you say the only way to confront
some of these people might be by doing
something like this now again I I'm not
saying I like this approach or that I am
necessarily against it I think it's a
difficult and complicated thing it's
it's come up when we talk about
protesting outside the homes of senators
or Supreme Court Justices and they're
sort of like the legal question but
there's also the moral and ethical thing
and I I I'm just not completely sure I
think there is some gray area but
specifically when we're talking about
elected officials whose salaries are
paid by taxpayers I understand that if
they make the decision that they are
going to hide from any kind of public
accountability
you can end up in a situation where you
say there's no way to even get my point
across to this elected official whose
salary I pay with my taxes other than
going up to them in public now going up
to them in public and screaming insults
if that's what happened not particularly
productive or or effective so let me
know your thoughts about this
um but the the term attacked that
Marjorie Taylor green is using at least
by everything I've read appears to be a
bit of an exaggeration we have a
voicemail number that number is 219 to
David P we haven't heard from him for a
while
But Eric from Mass Eric from
Massachusetts uh who has been insisting
for years I'm about to get sued I'm
about to get arrested I'm about to get
imprisoned because I quote promoted the
vaccines by which he means I reported
the scientific information about them he
now it it's really going to happen now
I'm really about to get arrested now
hey David from math get ready uh the
Bronson case from the Supreme Court is
about to come through and um all your
buddies uh your government
um ones you know I'm on every day are
going to be all uh replaced and fired
and probably arrested
um what they did was illegal
and what did they what did they and I do
you're on record saying you want to go
by the Constitution and
well you probably know all this you just
hide it for me
um people because the Democrat Party is
burning down just like uh
authoritarianism Republicans
authoritarian a scientists of
authoritarian when he let people go to
work uh not wear masks not have to get
vaccinated man this guy is obsessed huh
man you have a backwards back without
work on life
you destroyed people's lives Democrats
destroyed the country I'm not even a
Democrat and I had no no influence
whatsoever on policy so I don't know how
I destroyed anyone's life he destroyed
people's lives
all over a common cold
I mean
you know you talk about critical
thinking how can you possibly critically
think that some guy on TV tells you to
get a shot
oh
you can get either of the dirt or
horrified or Nixon and vacuum you can't
mix and match drums
wait
someone on the TV said you could
so Eric from Mass still fully on and
very very dangerous stuff going on over
there but I am standing by for when they
take me away in handcuffs uh let's see
if and when it happens I'm sure it will
be much to Eric's Delight if it does
we've got a great bonus show for you
today we will talk about this new low
confidence report from the Department of
energy
about the oranges of covid we will talk
about the NPR layoffs and what is going
on in media with the layoffs and we will
give you the latest on Senator John
fetterman and his path to recovery all
of those stories and more on the bonus
show
the bonus show folks get the bonus show
sign up at joinpakman.com you can use
the coupon code please no more Trump
that's the code all one word no spaces
please no more Trump it'll save you a
bundle and then we'll see you on the
bonus trip
foreign